dans quel monde vivront nos enfants dans
40 ans mais où est née il ya six mois
comme des centaines de milliers
d'enfants dans le monde et jamais la
situation écologique n'a été aussi grave
alors qu'est ce qu'on va leur dire à nos
enfants cas aucune solution c'est ça
qu'on va leur dire pendant sept ans j'ai
dirigé une ong
j'ai essayé par tous les moyens de
montrer que nous devons changer nos
façons de vivre sans quoi nous courons à
la catastrophe mais les gens ne veulent
plus qu'on leur dise que les choses vont
mal tout va déjà trop mal elle s'acharne
à répéter mais ça ne sert à rien alors
nous avons décidé de tenter quelque
chose de nouveau
arlon
mais là
ma
tu es là
gandhi disait montrer l'exemple n'est
pas la meilleure façon de convaincre
c'est là seulement partout sur la
planète des hommes et des femmes invente
un autre monde qui respecte la nature et
les humains d'autres façons de faire de
l'agriculture de l'économie
d'autres formes d'éducation de
démocratie je connais beaucoup d'entre
eux j'ai enquêté sur la solution j'ai
collecté tellement de matière tellement
de choses qui pourraient nous donner
envie de faire mieux d'être plus
intelligent
nous allons prendre la route et nous
allons les films et raconter leur
histoire notre histoire histoire de nos
enfants de notre futur rien n'est plus
puissant qu'une histoire qui nous fasse
rire pleurer qui nous donne envie de
nous retrousser les manches pour la
première fois nous allons mettre toutes
ces solutions bout à bout et montrer à
quoi notre commande pourrait ressembler
demain